[موسيقى]
افتكر من سنه 97 الازهر ودار الافتاء مجمع
البحوث موافق الناس مش عايزه تسمع مع انه
كل سنه بنقول انه حلال حلال حلال بس لسه
الناس قافله
وانها على الشاشه الشعراوي الشيخ الشعراوي
له كل الاحترام بس هو انسان ممكن يصيبه
[موسيقى]
دار الافتاء بحثت هذا الملف وحين سئلنا
عنه اا
وضعنا لذلك ضوابط وقلنا ان هذا لا يتعارض
مع الشرع بل هو من التداوي الذي
امر الله به ورسوله صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم بل وهو من احياء النفس كما قال تعالى
ومن احياها فكانما احيا الناس جميعا
[موسيقى]
احنا لما اييي افتينا بان هذا لا يتعارض
مع الشرع وضعنا لذلك ضوابط ومن هذه
الضوابط المهمه الا يكون في هذه العمليه
او في هذا الاجراء تمثيل بجثه الانسان
والتمثيل عشان نفهمه صح هو ليس مجرد ان
انا اا اشرط فيه او افتح او اخذ لا
التمثيل فيه معنى الاهانه انني افعل ذلك
واتركه كما هو لكن اذا كان هذا في سياق من
التكريم ومن الاحترام زي اي انسان بيعمل
عمليه وهو على قيد الحياه
[موسيقى]